monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission monsieur le rapporteur
général chers collègues nous examinons
un projet de loi de finance relevant
d'une nouvelle catégorie distincte de
celle des lois de finances
rectificativ contrairement au projet de
loi de finance rectificative il ne peut
contenir aucune disposition fiscale
nouvelle ce dont ce que nous regrettons
contrairement au rapporteur général car
cette interdiction corsette un peu plus
les droits du Parlement
d'emblé il me paraît ortun de souligner
que plusieurs dispositions monsieur le
ministre semblent aller dans le bon sens
les crises sont encore présentes et
elles risquent de se multiplier à
l'avenir de sorte que des moyens
supplémentaires sont nécessairire pour
accueillir les réfugiés soutenir nos
agriculteurs et maintenir n notre
soutien à l'Ukraine mais également à nos
concitoyens les plus précaires nous
saluons d'ailleurs le travail des
collègues socialistes à l'Assemblée
nationale qui ont proposé et obtenu une
rallonge de la prime de Noël pour les
familles monoparentales vivant sous le
seuil de pauvreté c'est ainsi entre 115
et 200 € supplémentaires par foyer pour
environ 500000 familles soit 70 millions
d'euros pour
2023 néanmoins ce que l'on peut retenir
de ce texte c'est une charge de la dette
bien plus élevée que ce que vous aviez
prédit je tiens notamment à souligner le
le différentiel important à hauteur de
3,8 milliard d'euros en raison notamment
des OAT indexés sur
l'inflation en parallèle nous constatons
que là encore les recettes ne sont pas
au
rendez-vous les dividendes de de l'État
sont inférieurs aux prévisions à hauteur
2,5 milliards d'euros et la contribution
sur la rente infra marginale de la
production d'électricité ayant a été
surévalué de 9,5 milliards d'euros dans
la loi de finance initiale pour 2023
quelle n'a pas été notre surprise à la
découverte de ces chiffres car vous
n'avez eu de cesse de cléronn dans
toutes les dans tous les médias de votre
farouche volonté de faire contribuer les
énergéticiens à hauteur de plus de 12
milliards d'euros ceuxci n'auront en
définitive que bien peu participer là
encore alors que les ministres se flatte
d'un financement historique de la
transition écologique pour le budget
pour 2024 plus d'1,3 milliard d'euros de
crédit de paiement sont annulés sur la
mission écologie sur cette somme 1,1
milliard d'euros était prévu pour le
programme 174 qui finance notamment ma
prime renove le chèque énergie et l'aide
à l'acquisition de véhicules propres et
105 millions devrai contribuer au
financement des infrastructures de
transport en la matière le rapport Pisan
ferie n'a pas été tendre avec le
gouvernement et alors que des membres du
GC prennent publiquement la parole
sortant de leur traditionnelle réserve
pour exprimer l'absence de cap du
président dans la politique écologique
du pays il semble difficile au regard de
la sous-exécution desd crédits de
l'ordonné
tort toujours dans la sous-exécution des
budgets il est notable que dans la
mission économie dont je suis cor
rapport avec coapporteur pardon avec ma
collègue Frédérique Espagnac le guichet
temporaire d'aide aux entreprises très
consommatrices d'électricité ou de gaz
qui été doté en 2022 et 2023 de 7
milliards d'euros de crédit n' à ce jour
sur les 44000 dossiers qui ont été
déposés traités que 17000 validés pour
un montant total d' de 832 millions
d'euros soit moins de 12 % des crédits
ouverts prenant Act de cette très forte
sousexécution vous avez d'ailleurs
annulé 4 milliards d'euros en septembre
dernier dans un tout autre registre nous
déplorons que l'article 2 ne prévoit pas
une compensation intégrale des
exonérations de cotisation sociale ce
qui mécaniquement ponctionne de 2
milliards d'euros les réserves de
l'unéic cette ponction annoncé cette é
dans une lettre de cadrage transmise au
syndicat n'est pas acceptable mais elle
n'est pas surprenant non plus car il
faut le dire en la matière vous n'êtes
pas votre coup d'essai vous aviez déjà
un temps envisagé de Pioger dans les
réserves de l'agir Carco par ce mode de
fonctionnement vous passez par-dessus
les organisations syndicales mais c'est
surtout et c'est le plus grave vous
attaquez frontalement le paritarisme qui
je le rappelle est le fondement de la
sécurité sociale enfin pour les
collectivités locales le compte n'y est
toujours pas et les courriers de la DG
FIP pour 3425 collectivités qui vont
devoir rembourser tout ou partie de la
compte qu'elles avaient reçu dans le
casadre du filet de sécurité pour un
montant de 70 millions d'euros n'est pas
de nature à soutenir nos collectivités
dont les budgets sont déjà durement
touché par l'inflation sans rentrer dans
les détails que ma collègue Isabelle
briquet exposera nous espérons que
l'amendement que nous proposons visant à
annuler la demande de remboursement des
accomtes perçus par ces communes
trouvera grâce à vos yeux vous l'avez
compris pour le groupe socialiste ce
premier
plfg ne nous convint pas en l'état nous
serons donc attentifs au débat en séance
publique car si nous parvenons à
améliorer le projet de loi notamment au
bénéfice des collectivités territoriales
nous pourrions consentir à ne pas nous y
opposer je vous remercie merci cher
collègue la parole est maintenant
monsieur Stéphane
Sar